well I think I you know it's interesting
I read something the other day that has
made a very interesting point i think it
was in conjunction with the debate that
was on youtube where citizens civilians
is we would call them ask questions as
opposed to reporters and the debate just
as silly as the other debates i mean
with nine people it's not all your
debate is just sort of nonsense
soundbite thing but the interesting
thing is not the answers but the
questions on reporters tend to ask
questions about how the campaign's going
or how something's going to play
compared to something else the reporters
are generally interested in the process
and that's what's so stupid about saying
oh you know eighty percent of them vote
democratic something they don't in the
first place they're not ideal logs that
that's just how they vote but they but
also they're much more interested in the
game than they are in in the ideology
and and reporters in general are are
interested in politics and bored by
government so that's why the minute the
election is over they start talking
about the next election and that's why
when you think about it about eighty
percent I'm just made up that figure of
the coverage of an American election is
about who's going to win something we're
all going to know on election night even
if the reporters were all death rate
we're still going to know what they're
going to count the vote so we're going
to know who won so why do they keep
telling us who's going to win or lose
it's not really the point rather than
tell us what that guy really believes or
what is likely to do I think I think
that that the other thing reporters
ought to try to do is is
and I you know I don't mean that they
don't do some of this but the actual
issues of a campaign aren't usually the
issues that the president deals with I
mean if you voted on the issues you
would have voted for what's discussed in
the campaign you would have voted in the
Kennedy Nixon election according to what
your beliefs were on the future of the
islands of chemo and Matsu that became a
big issue between Kennedy and Nixon
would we go to war to protect key moya
matsu two islands off Taiwan that were
sometimes shelled by the mainland come
communist China um that's not the
difference between kennedy and nixon and
that's not course once the election was
over that was the end of chemo omatsu
nobody's heard of key moya matsu since
so i think that that that somehow
election coverage should should really
tell us kind of person is that because
the decisions he's going to make or not
the decisions that are talked about
during the campaign there there other
there other decisions
you